Shane Stanley, Filmmaker/Author/Instructor:
They're not afraid to rub people wrong,
they're not afraid to piss people off, they're
not afraid to fail, they're going to go down in
a ball of flames and they are going to do it
their way, but man if it works, watch out...
Film Courage: If you're not pissing
someone off, you're not being
heard? Shane: Sure. Film Courage: What's the logic
behind that? Shane: Well, I think that as artists
we are all looking for our voice. I think we're
all looking to turn heads and if you kind of just
fall into the norm and you just kind of
do what everybody thinks you should do,
you're not going to get the attention you deserve.
Think about the films that have truly been game
changers or the songs or the other works of
art it's because people were weren't afraid to
think outside of the box or think left of left
and and change scares people we talked earlier
about fear especially with the executives
in this industry and um i just think that
you know if we're coming off of a time where
there's been so much hatred passed back and forth
especially on social media between different sides
of the fence right and at the end of the day we're
all humans we need to we need to unite but what
what is apparent is if you just follow like sheep
and just kind of go about your merry way you're
just you're gonna you're gonna fit nicely into
a mold and they're going to compartmentalize
you and i think some of the artists that i've
respected most um they're not afraid of pissing
people off and making change and making success
come their way because they weren't afraid to to
rub people the wrong way they weren't afraid to
give somebody the big fu and say i'm doing it this
way and i don't need your money i don't need your
distribution we're just gonna go do it i mean you
know robert rodriguez is a classic example dennis
hopper you know when him and peter fonda went
out and did easy rider some of the people that
i admire as filmmakers i mean you know looking
at somebody like hal needham um who you know
came from a tough stuntman background and and
understood the workings of how to make a movie
you know breaking them down from shot to shot
to working with the editors the producers the
directors the actors the stuntmen and finally just
woke up one day and started making these great
movies and you know i'm inspired most by rebels
i'm inspired most by people that weren't afraid
if people were going to approve doesn't mean
you're going to be successful but you know i think
i think there's certain things as artists
that that we have a responsibility to do
i mean art is what changes the world
movies movies hollywood songs they
they set the tone for a culture they
change trends you know like that and that's
exciting to me and you know when you hear me
say if you're not pissing people off you're
not being heard well if you're just falling into
what everybody else is doing you're just falling
into what everybody else is doing you know
quentin tarantino became who he was because
he did things his way he he was willing to roll
the dice and fortunately found people that were
willing to roll the dice with him you know robert
rodriguez mike figgis we talked about him earlier
um dennis hopper al needham i mean some of these
great filmmakers that just they're not afraid to
rub people wrong they're not afraid to piss
people off they're not afraid to fail they're
going to go down and a ball of flames are going
to do it their way but man if it works watch out
and that just is kind of that mindset so maybe
it doesn't mean deliberately trying to piss
people off but but knowing that they're going
to be people that are going to be offended or a
they themselves feel they can't do that so
they don't want you to do it because absolutely
their social structure wouldn't approve them oh
absolutely i mean i can't tell you how many times
i would get calls from people that i had produced
with in the past that would say to me you know i'm
really concerned that this investor may go on imdb
and see some of the things you've done in the past
whether it was with zalman king or charlie sheen
or whatever and i'm like yeah okay so what's the
problem you know they've had a pretty good run
and you know it's this fear and of you know maybe
certain people would be nervous or whatever and
i i never understood that i i would always ask
him to please explain that to me you know charlie
somebody i was very proud of having a history with
uh in my career and is very instrumental in
getting me to where i am in my life and for
somebody to come along and and be nervous about
the rebellion of of a charlie sheen or a bad boy
and and somebody who who made some of the
most incredible erotic cinemas almond king
and you know those are people that basically
gave people the middle finger and did what
they wanted to do i mean one of my favorites
almond king stories and we didn't talk about
this before we talked about suits and artists
was i remember working with zalman on a film
and an executive from the studio was there we
were on the other side of the world we were
in bali indonesia and there was somebody there
telling him how something had to be done and he
oh absolutely it went through this whole dog
and pony show that was so unsolvent at the time
and the guy left he just turned around and
goes [ __ ] him he goes watch how we do this
and he's got to remember something he goes if
you're going to if you're going to do something
you do it your way you just got to learn how to
tap dance and tell people what they want to hear
so they give you the opportunity to do it
because remember if you screw up you're done
but if you're successful they'll take
the credit for it but you'll work again
and you know that's that's kind of it i just you
know i i just i went through a phase where i was
getting calls from a lot of i don't know more
prim and proper entities that weren't much into
the mentality of just going out and doing
what you want to do everything was very
structured everything was very formulaic
which is not something that i fall well into
and i just found that there was a lot of things
that they were trying to to reshape or curb or
you know kind of protect from certain people
they were involved with knowing it's like well
you know there is something called the internet
it's all out there you know but my point is is
that i learned really quickly that there there
are a lot of people that as you said it's fear
they they're afraid of being looked at as a rebel
or somebody who likes to kick the dirt or whatever
and i i personally don't don't care i personally
don't care you know do what you want do what you
love love what you do and and do what feels right
in here as long as you're not hurting anybody
and if it pisses people off say the video well
good i'm glad i got some free rent in your head
you think people are scared of that
personality type because it can't be controlled
i i think there's i you know i think it's not
about trying to be rebellious or being controlled
i think yeah there's a lot of people that want to
try to conform you especially as artists into what
they want you to be or what their end game is um
i think a lot of there's so many intricate parts
in filmmaking you know there are people that
bridge the money together with the product and
then the product with the artist and the artists
with the output and there's so many people that
have to be kept happy and again it goes back
to i think executives and artists being able
to learn how to communicate better better lines of
communication and understanding each other better
but i think that there is a lot of fear and and
we've been fortunate in working with people in
in our circle that the decision makers that come
at our end who are the ones writing our checks
they they love what we do they get what we do
and they trust us and they say we're doing this
because we believe in you we're doing this because
we like what you do and what you represent so go
do it and and that's it doesn't matter if they're
giving you five dollars for a film or five million
for a film it's just about working with people who
understand you and if if you're a true artist and
there are things that you want to express there's
things that you want to experiment with i think
you need to respect yourself enough to do that i'm
all for doing work to get paid you know that we've
all been works for hire things that we wouldn't
put on our resume or maybe things that we're
not excited about there's nothing wrong go work
every time you work you're going to learn every
time you get another credit you know you'll put
some groceries away in the in the cupboards and
you get to eat and it's fun you get to pay rent
and all that fun stuff but i think you also have
to remember to allow yourself that freedom and
to be able to do that and i think yeah there's
a lot of people that are afraid i know i was
working with somebody in the past that was
working with some entities that were not exciting
to me and there was there was a concern about what
i represented as a filmmaker what my attitude is
and making the films that i want to make and where
they were thriving and other networks and other
outlets that were like oil and water and i finally
got to the point i was like you got to pick a side
you know you're either going to you're going to do
what i do or you're gonna keep doing that which
no disrespect that's that's cool pays your bills
but if you're gonna come here you're not gonna
stifle what i do hoping that these other entities
are not offended because you're affiliated with me
i don't embarrass anybody i'm not gonna you know
kill puppies or beat children but there is certain
types of mentalities mindsets and content that we
make that may not fit on the family channel and
that's just not kind of content i want to make so
yeah i think there's a lot of people who try to
stifle and try to conform artists into being what
they want them to be for the wrong reasons and
that's that's to me is you know that could be
very dangerous for the artist did you watch the
queen's gambit i actually did i was afraid you're
gonna ask me if i saw something which i didn't see
oh okay thank you thank you for not asking myself
richardson okay sure so so forgive me i'm blanking
on the character's name but thomas brodie sanctu
sangster if i i hope i'm saying his name right
so the one that's like this rebel chess player
who kind of saunters him he's kind of the james
dean right he's the genius yeah and then once you
finally get to know him he's actually a sweetheart
but he has this mystique and this persona
of this bad boy chess player amongst some
very cookie cutter intellectual overthinking
you know stanford graduates right exactly smart
people smart people but but also very invested
in their identities as smart people yeah and
so this guy comes in and he's just like this
you don't know what to make of them you're
fascinated by them but anyway so i just it kind of
reminds me of that i just that's a great analogy
it was a great show we really enjoyed that i think
like the rest of the world we caught that during
covet we didn't buy a chess set afterward um but
uh yeah and you know i think there are ways and
i hate to keep bringing them up and and i owe
so much of my career to zollman zalman king if you
don't know who he is look him up um zolman took me
under his wing you know 25 years ago and i learned
more from my my years with zalman than anybody
and zalman was a true rebel i mean he was a golden
globe nominated actor turned writer who wrote you
know nine and a half weeks with his wife and and
went on to direct some of the most incredible
incredible cinema um and nobody told a story
through a lens like solomon nobody could
and the careers he launched and discovered are
endless whether you talk about mickey rourke or
kim bassinger or you know david david duchovny
and uh just the list goes on and on and on and
my point is solomon had a relationship his
partner was it was a man who i still very
close to by the name of david saunders david
david was running one of the the sub studios
under sony when peter gruber was there and zalman
and this suit became friends and they wound up
creating red shoe diaries and launching show
timing that was really their first series
and built an empire on this this incredible
series starring a guy that nobody knew about
called david duchovny that you know just opened
the letters and read them and read them to his
dog usually and made these incredible women
empowering erotic cinnamon the relationship
that i most admired of all the relationships
i've known in hollywood was solomon and david
and just talk about mutt and jeff you know apples
and fork trucks young and yang and boy were they
were they that's the kind of relationship
executives and and artists should have because
they they conquered the world i mean you may not
like what they did but they conquered the world
yeah i think each needs each other because
because one is going to have one skill set
that the other doesn't have and vice versa
and absolutely one will be organized one
will be sort of a beautiful world be very
unorganized yeah and they need each other
and they really they really fed off of one
another and there was nobody better in the room
they would fight like cats and dogs i remember
you know david duchovny said when zolman passed
it he was a true artist he'd think more about
the curtains in the room and the color and the
sheen they would give off off a certain light
at the certain time of day he would shoot
zomling focus on that for hours and then you
know want something painted a certain color and
dave would come in and say whoa whoa whoa back up
how much money are you spending on painting these
things you know how much you spending on this
fabrics element well well that's that's insane
you can't do it they'd fight well then ethan i'm
not doing a movie david look at me sorry shane
movies canceled have a good life you know and i
i just slowly go for a walk i knew they'd fix it
and they always did they did that you know almost
every day but they were an incredible dual duo and
that's the kind of relationship that i i wish
for artists to have with somebody because they
they really david was the business and zollman was
the artist and boy did they just they were amazing
you